[موسيقى]
في الوقت الذي كانت توجد فيه قطارات مشهورة، كان
هذا القطار يتمتع بمكانة رمزية مطلقة في
أمريكا،
كتب فرانك سيناترا هذا القطار في
لوسيل بول والت ديزني،
هذا هو القطار الذي تريد رؤيته
[موسيقى]
نحن في رحلات استكشافية لسكك حديد نهر هدسون
والتي  هي رحلة ليوم واحد عبر نهر هدسون
على متن عربتي قطار تاريخيتين يمكننا
تشغيلهما في نفس المكان الذي كانت تسير فيه
في الأربعينيات وعلى هذا الطريق
بين نيويورك وألباني، نعطي
الناس لمحة عما كان عليه السفر
في أفضل حالاته  عندما كان السفر جيدًا كما
كان من قبل
[موسيقى]
أنت تقف في هذه
البقعة الصغيرة هنا في نهاية الردهة،
كان القطار المحدود في القرن العشرين هو
أشهر قطار في العالم وهو ليس لقبًا
أطلقوه على أنفسهم، بدأ القطار
في عام 1902  لقد أرادوا أن يكونوا أفضل
تجربة على Rails، لقد حققت
نجاحًا فوريًا إلى حد كبير، كانت هذه سيارة كانت
إعلانًا قديمًا حصلت على
الفاتورة الأولى وجميع إعلاناتهم تحدثوا
عن الديزل المبسط، صالة Lookout
Lounge، كانت هناك مسرحية في برودواي حول
هذا القطار هناك  كانت هناك أفلام عن هذا
القطار ومع هذا القطار، أعلم أنني
أبدو مألوفًا بشكل غامض، نعم
دائمًا أشرب الجين مع طفل
لا يمكنك معرفة ما إذا كنت قد قطعته، هل
يعرف أي شخص سبب أخذ
هاتفك؟ أريد أن أكتب شركاء، معظم
الناس لا يعرفون  لا أعرف أين هي سيدة القرن العشرين،
الجميع يعرف ما هي
السجادة الحمراء، كما تعلم أن السكك الحديدية
اخترعت السجادة الحمراء، كيف يمكنك
فصل قطارهم الرئيسي عن جميع
القطارات الأخرى في محطة غراند سنترال التي
كانوا يفرشون سجادتنا الحمراء
كل يوم  هذا هو المكان الذي يأتي منه هذا
جزء كبير مما جعل هذا
القطار مبدعًا في الثقافة الشعبية لذلك
لا يمكننا فعل ذلك
[موسيقى] تمت
استعادة هذه السيارة بعدة خطوات
أبعد من مجرد قطار المتحف العادي الخاص بك في أقرب وقت
ممكن، نجعل تلك الغرف
تبدو  تمامًا كما فعلوا في عام 1948. هذه
هي صالة المراقبة، السيارة الأخيرة في
القطار هي أكثر سيارة مقدسة في
القطار بينما تم
تصميم الصالة خصيصًا لمشاهدة المعالم السياحية، ولم يكن هناك
سوى سيارتين فقط من هذه السيارات للذهاب في
أي اتجاه أنت فقط  كنا
سنراهم في هذا القطار في
القرن العشرين المحدودة،
نحن نطعمك في القطار اعتمادًا على
الطبقة التي تنتمي إليها، إما أننا نوفر لك
السندويشات أو في هذه السيارة
نطبخ لك بالفعل في القطار، كان هذا هو
ما كانت السكك الحديدية تبيعه في
الأربعينيات هذا هو ما نبيعه اليوم
[موسيقى]
أعتقد أنه كان فريدًا جدًا أن
تنغمس فيه متى ستتاح لك
فرصة القفز على قطار من
الأربعينيات، مقاعد الجلوس ذات القماش
لمسة صغيرة على السجادة الحمراء إذا كنت تريد ذلك
ملابس أنيقة، افعلها بشكل صحيح، إنها
لقطة رائعة بعد خمس دقائق، كانت
تستحق العناء، نحن نفعل هذا ليس
للدفاع عن السفر بالسكك الحديدية بشكل مباشر
ولكننا جزء من القصة كما كانت عليه من قبل  منذ وقت
ليس ببعيد، كان
بإمكاننا الحصول على هذا مرة أخرى إذا اخترنا
الحصول عليه
[موسيقى]